all right we're talking with Brian and
firming him his wife is a banker it was
$20,000 on the $15,000 to call $8,000 on
credit cards and they make about $90,000
a year and that's about how far we got
in the discussion is that a fair summary
of what you told me so far sir Lisa
sounds good to me that's right how can I
help today then all right you know I've
introduced the idea of sowing the comer
here recently and I guess due to
circumstances of these switching
vehicles you know as you can tell twice
in the past in a couple of years it
seems to be that if I want to you know
keep my relationship was whole life on
Good Standing I don't like good stuff I
don't she doesn't want to sell the car
she doesn't really want to see that as
an option and get something cheaper so
I'm really trying to find a another
avenue that I can really bite some of
this debt down whether it's equity in
the car or the credit cards just any
other option besides plugging her with
an idea that she's not gonna be kosher
with so I don't think this is gonna work
because you two are not on the same page
with your financial goals correct and
it's not about the goal of selling the
car it she doesn't care whether she's
out of debt or not and you're fired up
about getting out of debt and so you're
always going to run into financial
disagreements in this marriage
she's a banker she loans money for a
living and so you're gonna struggle with
that as long as she thinks keeping a
$20,000 car dad around is okay then
you're all are going to struggle if you
don't think it's okay because if it's
not this it's gonna be something else
later if she wants to go on vacation she
wants to buy something else y'all can't
afford she wants to do something you you
know the problem is not the car the
disagreement of the car the disagreement
of the car is the symptom of the fact
that you all aren't on the same page
about money and so I would back up and
spend
a lot of time on that and then decide
what to do with the car as a separate
issue but I think the two of you need to
talk about where you want to be
financially in ten years and what the
best route to get there is if she thinks
borrowing your way into wealth is going
to get her there all the data points say
she's wrong all the millionaire's that
we've studied for the last twenty years
and in this last study we've just
completed a huge study of millionaires
we find that they stay out of car debt
and out of credit card debt and it's the
shortest path to being a millionaire
regardless of if someone says that at
the bank or not right and so you guys
have got to decide if you agree about
that kind of thing then you say okay as
a part of us getting out of debt in
order to build wealth is selling the car
the best route now I think you could
probably keep the car actually with your
income the guidelines that we use is can
you be debt-free in two years not
counting your house and keep the car the
answer to that is yes if the two of you
were on the same page making what you
make you could pay off fourteen thousand
a year in two years
easy easy right gives me some hope okay
the second thing is you know is the car
as a total of all your cars worth more
than half your handle income and the
answer there is no because I'm guessing
she's not driving a thirty five or forty
thousand dollar car that's paid for it
right negative right here exactly right
okay what's her car worth her quarters
worth she drives a Ford Explorer and you
know it's it's not the cheapest model so
why is it wonderful
that's a good question I think I haven't
looked at the Kelly Blue Book now so I'm
gonna go ahead and say I don't know
okay I like ten grand yeah so you got
you got twenty five thousand dollars for
the cars and you make 90 that's
reasonable okay if they were both paid
for and if you can pay for this one in
two years and your credit cards I'd be
fine but dude that involves the two of
you sacrificing getting on a budget
together and a
reading that this subject overall of
handling money towards debt-free is the
shortest path to wealth and to live your
dreams you're not in agreement about
that now that is a big issue at your
house this car is a small issue and so
you can't say oh I'm not gonna pay I'm
not gonna sell the car just to make her
happy because it's not the car that's
making her upset
it's the fact you all aren't on the same
page and that's what you've got to get
to agreement on for the sake of your
marriage you need to